le parti socialiste on le disait tout à
l'heure il a vécu d amour avec son
propre parti sur ces images un brigitte
macron brigitte qui est dans ce
vestibule de l'elysée l'entretien entre
régimes ma chronique il est en régime
c'est un j'ai joui est donc terminée les
deux hommes
elsa devrait donc sortir dans les
secondes qui viennent maintenant que man
on les voit d'ailleurs à l'écran
la françois hollande 1 emmanuel macron
qui descendent donc donc ces marches
une ville chaleureuse à brigitte mac on
pense au monde kim a salué le chef du
protocole et le moment fatidique où
emmanuel macron var accompagné son
prédécesseur son client
[Musique]
ils descendent le père on le perd on est
enceinte d'un mur qu'on entend les
applaudissements emmanuel macron qui a
l'air d'avoir l'intention de
raccompagner françois hollande jusqu'à
sa voiture deux hommes se sont sûrement
mis d'accord sur cette scénographie et
voilà on sera à quelques mètres avant on
est on est plus dans le style de la
passation entre entre françois
mitterrand et jacques chirac 1 les deux
hommes qui s'arrête au milieu du tapis
rouge emmanuel macron qui va donc
laisser françois hollande regagne et
seule sa voiture poignée de main
chaleureuse emmanuel mapuche souligne un
des plusieurs personnes applaudissent
tech qui applaudit également françois
hollande qui monte à l'intérieur de sa
voiture la ds console à l'écrit telle
émotion chez françois hollande l'homme
il roule la voiture sont arrêtés au
droit du numéro au millimètre près et
mieux m'a confié dont celle sur le tapis
rouge françois hollande qui salue la
foule à la fenêtre de sa voiture
[Applaudissements]
et l'elysée pour remonter les marches du
perron comme celui de jacques chirac
c'est une chorégraphie condom on
retrouve des éléments de tous les
bénévoles toutes les passations sont de
celles de françoise enock lui-même on
imagine via plus de marques
d'improvisation c'est le cas
vous pourrez manu et le maquereau cloud
sur quitte le palais de l'elysée se
retrouvent dans la rue du faubourg
saint-honoré direction solférino pour
françois hollande emmanuel macron lui
direction le salon des ambassadeurs pour
emmanuel macron puisque vous voyez là en
direct un avec son épouse brigitte
maquereau ou poser pour les photographes
[Applaudissements]
enfin sauf en style peut-être sa plus
devient le couple présidentiel avait les
photographes du père sortir le coup
présidentielle pour qu'ils soient bien
il faut soleil à la vue de tous
premières photos donc officiel
présidentielle le couple qu'il va donc
alain disait se dirigeaient maintenant
vers le salon des ambassadeurs et
philippe goulliaud gagner une acrobate
pour simple dans l'escalier pour
peut-être rattrapé le retard sur
l'organisation prévu et c'est maintenant
un philippe goulliaud à proprement
parler le début de cette cérémonie
d'investiture
voilà le président comme je disais tout
à l'heure entre en scène et on va voir
effectivement quel est le message de son
de son premier discours là on voit
brigitte macron qui paraît que alexis
colère le nouveau secrétaire général
donc l'homme qui va être tout puissant
l'elysée celui qui va faire tourner la
machine
veillez à ce que le message du président
soit bien relayé par les députés les
ministres enfin voilà un personnage
considérable et manuellement un très
proche de manuel macron effectivement
qui a un peu le même parcours que lui
d'ailleurs je crois enfin c'est